Alastor start with you defense and
security does anything hang on
what Parliament serves today we'll do
what Britain does about its relationship
with you it does but I think some people
that exaggerated how much defence first
of all firstly our relationship the
primary alliance within Europe is NATO
and Britain's relationship with NATO
won't and shouldn't change and Britain
could and probably will partake in the
limited number of EU military operations
around the world going forward when it
comes to security there are some things
that need to be ironed out the issue of
data sharing for example Britain's
membership or role within the Schengen
and information system so that they can
share passport data the European Arrest
Warrant those are sort of things that
need to be sorted in some sort of
security agreement like trees made
called for the Munich Security
Conference last year but does this
brexit agreement fundamentally threaten
Britain's national security as Sir
Richard Dearlove the former head of mi6
and little Guthrie the formative the
defense staff claimed in that letter to
consider party chairman I don't think it
does
I think that's an exaggeration now what
can we say about Britain's 40-plus year
membership of the European Union and
previous organisations in economic terms
good thing or bad thing oh it's a tough
question I'm over the past 40 years
actually the UK has done a lot better
than over the previous 40 years I mean
that's that's the fact that we when we
joined the EU in the 1970s properly we
were we work in a weak position we were
you know heading for an IMF bailout and
since then we've done very well to what
extent was that down to the EU that's
something that economists are still
debating and I think actually you know
broadly speaking it is good to be part
of a big single market and that
you know you want as little in the way
of friction when you were trading with
any country or indeed group of countries
so that clearly most economists think is
a good thing but saying that the past 40
years of productivity growth is purely
down to the EU I think that's going way
too far and that that is not something
we're gonna get a definitive answer on
though I'm afraid Beth of course it's
about so much more than the economy is
there isn't it just I mean it's about
our destiny if you like and and how
parliamentarians think that destiny
should be shaped should it be a close
relationship with the EU will they try
and revoke article 50 will they try and
have a second referendum will they bat
Mays deal what today is about is a
actual moment in history and it really
is in terms of the enormity of this vote
just to put it into context as you were
saying earlier it could be the biggest
defeat for a sitting Prime Minister
we've ever seen on perhaps probably the
most the biggest decision Parliament's
had to make since the Second World War
in our modern political history and it
could also be the biggest rebellion
we've seen for many decades of a sitting
Prime Minister for her own MP so I'm
looking at the numbers on both of that
now in normal times what would happen is
that Prime Minister would probably come
out of Downing Street and say I've lost
the support of my partner I've lost the
support of my Parliament my government
can't govern and I resign but that's not
going to happen today because these are
extraordinary times